are closest to him and those
who are nearest to him. They
are not arrogant and find
themselves above the worship of
Allah nor do they ever cease in
their worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
What's meant by this is that
those who are closest to him
subhanahu wa ta'ala Speaking of
the closest angels. To Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. They are
not arrogant. Arrogance is
exact opposite of worship. As a
matter of fact, the word
etymologically of worship used
to denote worship in the Arabic
language is a reference to
humility.
Al Worship in the Arabic
language. the word literally
translates to humility. and so
when a person exhibits
arrogance This person negates
of his worship of Allah based
on the amount of arrogance that
he totes. For this reason, the
prophet has said
[Silence]
Whoever has a mustard seeds
weight of arrogance in his
heart will not be permitted to
enter paradise. and the more
arrogance there is the longer
that span and stint into
hellfire and
prohibition of paradise will be
upon that individual
The
reason for this is that we
were created for the worship of
Allah and inherently worship is
humility. arrogance and worship
are two opposites night
and day, black and white. They
cannot mix and be in the same
place at the same time.
whatever portion of a person's
heart is taken by arrogance,
worship is eradicated from that
place. And whatever place in a
person's heart, worship is
found, arrogance is not found.
They can't be in the same
place, in the same place. They
are mutually exclusive as it
were. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
continues to describe them
saying they glorify him and
praise Allah. Day, night, and
day. And they do not they do
not relent. Meaning, they are
in constant, praise of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Never
relenting not for a moment in
all of the things that they do.
As it is mentioned by our
scholars, that the angels of
their nature is to praise Allah
just as our nature is too.
Breathe. Just as we breathe in
and out. Likewise, the angels,
praise Allah, subhanahu wa
ta'ala in this way. As they go
about, whatever it is they are,
commissioned to do. Just as a
person walks and talks and
speaks and eats and sleeps
while breathing. Likewise, the
angels with regard to
glorifying Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. The prophet mentions in
Sahih Muslim, the authority of
Jabber. that the people of
paradise Will be inspired to
praise Allah as they are
inspired to breathe. They will
be inspired to praise Allah and
to thank Allah with every
breath that they draw.
by the
Subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Silence]
objects that they worship other
than Allah give life. This is
obviously a rhetorical
question. Meaning that, those
who worship other than Allah.
If we just look at
implausible nature of their
polytheism If we just observe
the nature of their beliefs,
that Allah, the almighty, who
has been previously described
in the, in the previous verses
Allah described himself as
creating the heavens and the
earth. He described himself as
being the maintainer of all
that exist. The one who is due,
all worship, and then he
describes as well. Those who
worship him. With the greatest
of descriptions. these
individuals are are not
arrogant. They are not prideful
and that they worship Allah day
and night. He then says
subhanahu wa ta'ala describing
those who are worshiped other
than he as a kind of contrast.
As the poet says,
If we look to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala's descriptions or
even a few of them. And try to
fathom And then we look at the
descriptions of those who are
worshiped other than Allah and
try to fathom. the chasm
between the two becomes very
prevalent in our minds eye. We
can now see the great distance,
the immeasurable distance
between Allah, Subhanahu wa
ta'ala and his stature and
those things or ones who are
worshiped other than Allah. He
says subhanahu wa ta'ala asking
rhetorically
asking rhetorically, have they
appointed objects of worship
from the earth which do not
give life to anything Why have
they turned away from the
worship of the one who is the
ever living who gives? Life to
all things. And from whose life
all life is derived. Is
derivative. Why would they then
direct any portion of their
humility, of their worship, of
their duty fullness
to
that which is intrinsically
dead That which is totally and
inherently reliant upon Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala for life
and sustenance and existence.
These things that are worshiped
aside from Allah. These persons
who are worshiped aside from
Allah. even their thoughts is
something which can only be by
the will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And by the creation of
Allah. even their idea is of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
creation of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's
permission. So, how can these
things be worshiped aside from
Allah? No matter who or what it
is and these things cannot give
the most minimum of life
requirements of their own of
their own power, and of their
own volition. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala then refutes this
idea of there being any other
god or sustainer aside from
him.
have there
been in the heavens
or in the earth, any god other
than Allah They would surely
They would surely spiral into
destruction
This this creation, the
heavens, the earth, the
dominion of the heavens and the
earth can only be maintained by
Allah. If any portion of this
dominion were to be subjugated
entirely to other than Allah
and maintained by other than
Allah.
harmony would be thrown out of
balance and it would quickly
devolve into chaos rather the
harmony that we see in the
world and the persistence of
existence and the persistence
of the nature of the world and
and all that we see around us
above us and below us and
around us. All of this is
maintained by Allah. It's
balance is there by Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala's constant
will and maintenance. If he
were to withdraw that will or
maintenance for a moment,
everything cease to be.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala
Subhan Allah. And if we
understand this, the next
logical step is that we turn
directly to Allah alone without
any partners. If we know that
there is no sustainer but
Allah, no maintainer but Allah,
no truly rectifying agents
other than Allah. Then, why
would we glorify other than
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala? If a
person truly believes that
Allah is one in his actions,
one in his names and
attributes, then why then?
Would a person worship other
than Allah? If one truly
believes that Allah is one, in
his essence, in his names and
attributes, in his actions,
then the next logical step must
be that only he be worshiped
and that we direct our humility
and our worship. and our
servant to Allah alone without
any partners. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
He says,
glory be to Allah, the
lord of the great throne and
far above is he from all that
day? Ascribe unto he
unrightfully. of his servants,
of the people, They ascribe to
Allah partners, children
Ascribe to Allah all kinds of
things. And Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is innocent and far
above all of these things that
they describe him with.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
[Arabic recitation]